[Musique]
ces sans abri dans l'émotion et diarra
met à table avec sa batte à raquettes de
ping pong je vous dis il m'a défié au
ping pong
je suis invaincu ici pierre ambroisiens
à l'air un même toit xala lagarde vice
versa est ce que tu as ton micro regarde
y en avait allez c'est parti
hier en barrage mon chéri ça fait six
ans j'ai mon émission s'est abattue mois
bien un truc a forcément un truc j'y
crois pas s'il ya des trucs avec les
vélos truqués et tous maintenant je dis
tu fais raquettes sont truquées ah non
non mon cher amener mon matériel pas six
mois et tu va choisir main gauche main
droite
ça y est ça la fout de ma gueule
non mais tu peux non mais elle est en
règle elle était désolée elle est
contrôlée et tout va bien présente à
l'évaluer avec ta raquette cette option
au fond deux points gagnants en deux
points gagnants pendant 3 comprend un
gars ne ralentit pas d'échauffement
n'avons pas d'échauffement fall et
chopin et fort y'a quoi gagner gagner ça
joue
nathalie steve haguy
joe hogan alors si tu gagnes pas parent
dîner avec kelis et kanye est ce que tu
veux bien qu'il ait fait en bois je te
demande bien sûr si je gagne jamais dit
isabelle morini-bosc dîner pour son
anniversaire
palin pour dire ça me va je me fait
kiffer et oui tu vois mal aller c'est
pas toi te revient dans sa toile 0,2 en
mai 0,1
quand tu t'es présente ici faut que tu
es un gros niveau tu crois quoi les
stresser pierre en bois toi
[Applaudissements]
non
comment
je prenne ma chambre